تعب اثناء اليوم وصعوبات في التركيز على
المهام والانتباه هذه اعراض معروفه نتيجه
قله النوم لكن يبدو ان التاثير اكبر من
ذلك بكثير بحسب دراسه استراليه وكنديه
جديده الدراسه كشفت ان لقله النوم اثار
كارثيه على صحه القلب فهي تؤثر بشكل كبير
على الدوره الدمويه وتقصر عمر القلب
النتائج كشفت ان اضطرابات النوم المرتبطه
بالتنفس ادت الى تقصير عمر قلب الشخص
حوالي سبع سنوات لدى النساء وست سنوات
ونصف السنه لدى الرجال وكان يبدو للنوم
تاثير كبير ايضا على اقتصاد العالم النوم
في السوق العالمي مع الزميل لميساء مع
الزميله لميس ابراهيم
قله النوم تؤثر على الاقتصاد بحسب دراسه
اجرتها مؤسسه الابحاث الامريكيه
وخلصت الى ان الدول تفقد ما يصل الى ثلاثه
بالمئه من انتاج المحلي الاجمالي بسبب قله
النوم ذلك نظرا لان النوم السيء يتسبب في
ارتفاع مخاطر الوفيات فضلا عن خسائر
الانتاجيه في العمل ما دعى الى نمو ويسمى
باقتصاد النوم الناس بداوا في ادراك نقصهم
للنوم خاصه بعد الوباء وحقيقه ان الناس
يعرفون انهم بحاجه الى الحصول على مزيد من
النوم المتواصل يعطي فرصه لشركات بيع
المراتب وحلول النوم الاخرى وتنقسم منتجات
وخدمات النوم الى ثلاث ثيات الاول تحسين
الاجواء ويشمل اثاثوره في النوم والتحكم
في الصوت ودرجه الحراره والثاني التعديل
الروتيني ويشمل استشارات النوم واجهزه
مراقبه النوم والمنبهات الذكيه اما العلاج
الثالث فيجمل وسائل المساعده على النوم
كالوصفات الطبيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على فكره هذا الموضوع بهمني كتير ناس وانا
متاكد في كثير خلف او امام الشاشه بشوفوا
يعني بتابعوا هالموضوع لانه في كتير ما
بحكوا عن هذا الموضوع بين اصدقاءهم
واصحابهم نعم والان في الاستوديو ينضم
الينا استشاري امراض القلب
التداخليه الدكتور احمد السكري صباح الخير
دكتور صباح الخير يعني السؤال البديهي انه
لماذا النساء
الدراسه تقول ان النساء هم اقل عرضه لهذا
لقله النوم من الرجال
طبعا
التكوين الفسيولوجي للرجال والعضو حتى
الرجال يختلف عن النساء يعني من اكتر
اسباب قله النوم في الرجال هي امراض
البروستاتا دي مش موجوده في النساء طبعا
تاني حاجه معظم الرجال هم اللي بيقوموا
بالواجبات العمليه يعني هم اللي بيتعرضوا
للسوق العملي اكتر من النساء يعني لو لو
بصينا لمعظم الرجال تقريبا ميه في الميه
من رجال بيعملوا فده بيؤدي الى زياده
الستريس والضغط تاني حاجه الراجل بطبيعته
هو مسؤول عن البيت يعني زوجته تعمل او لا
تعمل الرجل دائما بيكون هو مسؤول عن
مصاريف البيت والاولاد والمصاريف الاداريه
ده بيشكل بيشكل عبء على الرجل اكتر من
الست نفسها لكن هل في تغيرات هرمونيه تفرق
بين الراجل عن الست تخلي الست تنام اكتر
ايوه في تغيرات رمليه انتاج الميلاتونيه
الميلاتونين عند الرجل النساء اكثر من
رجال
الانتاج الكورتيزول اللي هو هرمون الفوقان
والصحيان عند الرجال اكثر من النساء فده
من احد الاسباب اللي تخلي الست تنام اسهل
واسرع من راجل
تاني حاجه الرجل اكثر عرضه لامراض زي
امراض السكر للنساء ليه لسبب واحد
الاستريسي بيتعرض له دايما في بيئه العمل
او سواء بيئه العمل والمسؤوليات اللي احنا
اتكلمنا عليها فبرده من الامراض السكر
يخليه كثير دخول مثلا التبول اثناء الليل
فده يؤدي الى ارق اكثر شويه فلو لو
اتكلمنا على الجزء السوشيال او الاجتماعي
الرجل بيشيل مسؤوليات اكتر شويه خلاص
ومسؤول مسئوليه كمان تفرقنا الى المشاكل
ما هي الحلول يعني انا وحده من الناس
اليوم اللي صار نومي جدا خفيف كان جدا
دقيق قبل بس اليوم يومي جدا خفيف انام
ساعات اقل بكثير واذا اصحى خلص ما ارجع
انام شو هي الحلول اللي ممكن تعطينا اياها
بالحاله سبب الاسباب يعني لو في سبب مرضي
مثلا زي ما قلنا في مرض السكر بيخليه يدخل
حمام كثير او يتبول كتير ليلا لازم يتعالج
مرض السكر لو في امراض في البروستاتا او
في المثانه البوليه لازم الامراض دي
تتعالج لو في امراض اجتماعيه يعني مثلا
بيئه العمل بتاعته او ضغط جامد بيئه العمل
لازم تتغير تاني حاجه في حاجه اسمها مرحله
التعود يعني اعود نفسي انام كويس يعني
لازم كل يوم مثلا من الساعه تسعه او تسعه
ونص لحد الساعه 11 اروح على السرير
اهيئ البيئه نفسها للنوم نفسها يعني اخلي
الضوء دائما منخفض لان الشاشات او او
الضوء الكتير بيخلي افراز الميلاتونين
اللي هو انزيم النوم يقل يعني مثلا
بيتعرضوا لشاشات كمبيوتر او او لاب توب او
موبايل اثناء النوم الضوء اللي خارج
دلوقتي
من من من الشاشه للعين بينبه المخازن قبل
ما اروح للفراش
يعني كم ساعه ولا نبي الساعه كم لا قبل ما
نفوت
ساعتين
30 ثانيه هل ما زالت نظريه التفكير
بالطبيعه والمناظر الطبيعيه تخفف او تساعد
على التخلص من هذا قله النوم او الدخول في
النوم العميق اذا صح التعبير اه طبعا
تغيير المكان يعني مثلا الناس لو انت رحت
الارياف من اكثر قدره على النوم ليه لان
ما عندهم ما عندهمش الهم اللي الدول اللي
هي المتقدمه او البلاد اللي هي المتقدمه
الحياه فيها اسرع بيئه العمل فيها اسوا
شويه والستريس ليفل فيها اعلى كتير
شكرا الدكتور احمد السكري كان معنا هنا في
استوديو للحديث عن هذا يعني امراض القلب
وهذا هذا المرض العاصي اذا حكينا قله
النوم على الاقل في هذه الاخير النوم هي
فتره الصيانه للجسم انت لو ما نمتش الجسم
غير قادر على صيانه نفسه فالنوم هي فتره
الصيانه والترميه شكرا